good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is our third day
being Quarren Steen's and you know what
I have officially snapped I did it you
guys you I snapped at my husband this
morning and you know what it was
unwarranted it was uncor n't it but it's
just it's been a lot you know what Ben
is on he had a sinus fight infection
last week and he's been on prednisone
you know the steroids that make you feel
so much better but their old man is
writing yeah they're behind like this
they're a shot of like adrenaline they
make there it's basically like a dorm
like you just want to be stimulated and
do stuff and he is being so [ __ ]
annoying like every ten seconds when I
play game 1 do something I'm like I'm
[ __ ] working like I'm watching
Heartbreakers he's just been so naggy
he's like I can't do this I'm like oh my
god if you're gonna be like this every
day it's only day three you got a chill
you've got a chance and then this
morning I snapped because he was just
like on me last night and then this
morning I was running really late and I
make the bed every single morning and I
can you just make the bed and I know
he's gonna be getting to that point to
where I'm like if you're gonna stay in
the bed I feel like the rule should be
last one in the bed makes that that's
why I always make the bad thing so I
know when Ben makes the bed it's like a
piece of [ __ ] but at least it's like 70%
of the work and I can fix it and he just
did it so like he didn't give a [ __ ] and
it's like I know it's not important to
you but it's important to me yeah and I
just [ __ ] snapped like I was in the
middle of getting dressing I'll just
[ __ ] do it like I know Ben doesn't
watch this [ __ ] which is like another
problem we're having but if you are
watching Ben I'm sorry like I know I was
wrong but like you were really just
being disrespectful to the bed no it's
good that he doesn't watch a show cuz
you get an hour a day where you can just
like vent about him but I do feel as
though in these quarren times the
mornings are actually the best cuz
that's when like you've forgotten all of
the fights of yesterday you're getting
ready to go somewhere like it's a new
fresh start maybe we won't fight today
maybe um so to have a fight in the
morning that's the shocking stuff yeah
and it was totally my fault and I own
that I was just being a [ __ ] but just
have some respect for the house and he's
just like keeps making dishes like who
the [ __ ] do you think is gonna do them
our housekeeper is warranty and she
cannot come and so I am the live-in
nanny and he's just like leaving stuff
around the house like who do you think
is gonna pick that up if it's not gonna
be you know and on top of that Zach and
I are filming our home tour today so
it's like pick your stuff up it's 4:00
our patreon channel you could subscribe
at patreon.com slash morning show so if
you're looking for extra content I'm
really excited about it cuz I've been
waiting to do a home tour but now it's
gonna be like quarantine edition and
you'll have to see like all the snacks
we're stocked up on very interesting
very critter we keep our toilet paper
etc so I'm really excited but my man's
got to pick his shoes up off the floor
so yeah if you need more content we're
also we've tons of content we were on
the ladie game podcast yesterday and the
reviews are in and they're rave guys my
month 5 podcast this week ok meet Jackie
and I are on Margaret Joseph's a new
episode it dropped today caviar dreams
tuna fish budget I'm on today's episode
of the snatchler and it's so good she
came over last night and we were just
like in my bed [ __ ] around and it was
hilarious
I'm also on actually I'm not sure about
food okay and um this podcast and my
home tour and lady game so we're just
like content queens some could say we're
content quarantine queens yeah um Wow I
mean the moaning coast is just really
like the bright spot in my day I mean
I'm so grateful that we like have our
studio which is so close to our house
and we can just be here just you and I
like we're not putting anything or
anyone at risk but we can still maintain
a level of normalcy like I am so
grateful same I took an uber here today
and my uber driver I got inside though
you guys I'm being so careful I wear one
latex glove if I'm ever gonna touch
anything I use the gloved hand and I
wash my hands immediately upon arrival
oh and I don't touch anything
and we're driver I got in he was like
what do you think about this coronavirus
and I was like I think it's crazy you
know what's what's there to think scary
times you know but I think we're taking
the necessary precautions and hopefully
we will limit the spread and he goes
well I'm sure you're hearing that it
started in Wuhan China but I have a
source that tells me it was man-made in
the USA and I was like oh really and he
was like yeah you're gonna see like when
the stalks jump back like you know the
rich get richer blah blah blah I'm like
okay so who made the virus who's behind
all this he was like I think it's Bill
Gates mmm I was like oh why he was like
because he he's making the vaccine I was
like uh yeah but I think he was just
like doing that out of the goodness of
his heart
you know how did that Bill and Melinda
Gates talk is going around where he said
the next pandemic isn't an if but a way
and I was like you should watch pandemic
on Netflix because it shows you that
like this sort of situation was sort of
inevitable I just don't think people
have been working on the X scenes for a
long time because we knew that this was
inevitable I don't think that Bill &
Melinda of the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation would just be spreading virus
isn't taking the lives of you
old people I just I I don't think so but
you know cab drivers and taxi drivers
for the longest time in New York have
been the source of many rumors and they
have actually gotten rumors like up to
the president like I remember when we
were in high school one girl was like my
cab driver told me there's gonna be a
terrorist attack you know in Harlem at
10:00 p.m. like literally uber 11th and
like when October 11th came like we know
our school was shut down yeah like there
were rumors and it always started from a
cab driver like this like random people
would be like my cab driver and it
became really legitimate rumors that
like authorities we're looking into when
I remember one time our school actually
got shut down for the day like so this
is not new you know taxi drivers
starting rumors but it's like you know
what else they gonna be right also it
was grateful for the conversation and I
like love a good conspiracy I was
sharing some of my thoughts you know but
it's just like these are the things we
have to entertain ourselves also it was
their mercedes-benz mattress which is
just like a great kind of car and like
the first block he didn't shut the doors
cuz they're automatic yes and I felt
like I was in the UPS truck instead also
when it comes to conspiracy theories as
we said yesterday it's very important to
not live your life you know abiding by
the conspiracy theories but always very
importantly keep them in the back of
your mind
so when it comes to the Bill and Melinda
Gates things I can't believe it but it
has now been filed in the file of
conspiracy theories in my brain in my
frontal lobe and that was just like his
theory on what he thought is fact which
is that the virus was man-made made in
the USA I personally don't subscribe to
that theory but I appreciate it at 100
did you see the news interview of
Governor Cuomo on CNN being interviewed
by his brother the Cuomo brother Chris
Cuomo Chris yeah I did not see this
Cuomo on Cuomo action oh my god they're
they're fighting like it was obviously a
joke but he was like he was like thanks
Governor Cuomo for being here and I'm
mom says call you mom says that you
should call her cuz you even called her
in like a week he's like actually I just
mom literally before this interview like
they started fighting on air it was a
joke but it was like it was like serious
like brother fight it was very funny and
I just think it's important like to take
a moment to give a big kudos to Governor
Cuomo because New York is one of the
most affected states and I think he's
doing a great job I think he's doing a
great job too and you know I don't think
it's doing a great job
our Mayor Bill DeBlasio he's not but you
know what it's great for him that he
works
Governor Cuomo cuz he gets like take
credit yes are things happening but
whoever thought he was gonna do a good
job and I feel like it's not even that
hard to do a bad job all you have to do
is just like the right thing yeah he's
just he's been absent um I heard he went
to the gym like that's what I heard do
you know what it's just as much as I'd
love to give praise I also have to say
you know when someone's not doing a good
job and New York deserves better because
New York is kind of the epicenter of the
virus in America that's when the first
case was and I just think Washington
whatever I just think if we could be
doing a better job and important no but
there's there's per capita we have the
most cases right here yeah that way
state is we're up there you know we are
up there we are five maybe even top
three okay so that's what I'm saying
sorry I didn't mean to spread
misinformation what I'm saying is that
we're really implicated than this and
he's just been so absent and every time
he gives the press conference he doesn't
you know and it's obviously used to do
the right thing but you also have to
make people feel safe you know when yeah
like he's just not he's there's nothing
endearing about it it's like I don't
mind that he's absent because I don't
want to hear from him you know yeah I
mean Governor Cuomo's hands take me
I feel Gary awake Wilma I feel very safe
in Governor Cuomo's arms there they're
very Mannion manly and warm and I feel
good about it so I just wanted to say
kudos hello
let me want to come on the show you know
let us know we are the only game in town
when it completes mama yes good boy come
on come on come on see all has been just
like a guiding light through this whole
process and that's been really wonderful
for me as a mom to see like all the work
I put into growing like making him be
like a decent human being he has
actually become and he's like not
panicking he's really really measured
he's been doing a lot of research she's
been doing a lot of Instagram wives
that's like a trend but Instagram was
blown I'm instagramming you know what
like I think there are some cool things
that people are doing Lou combs thank
you for the concert play John Legend
they're putting on concerts Jonas
Brothers we're doing something funny and
cool but like again I think really the
influencers are just like ruling
coronavirus right I mean a story about
that today also I was just again I'm
just being so negative today but I was
really disappointed in the livestream
given to me by Ben Platt because what do
you think you're gonna get from a
livestream of Ben Platt him and his
friend at a piano yeah no they were like
wearing sweat pants it's just dancing
like two nonsensical music and I didn't
get one bar from Ben plot we have tick
tock furred
yeah it was so unnecessary but I do like
the live element like I'm getting
concerts Luke Combs did a three-song
concert in his living room he also
recorded it on a real camera and
uploaded at his IG TV so you could watch
it after he did a cover a fast car which
it was so good and then he did a new
song and then hurricane and I just I
loved this format like I I love concerts
but I hate leaving my house so this is
perfect for me yeah I have to be honest
I haven't watched one of them I'm
grateful to all the people I'm grateful
glad to all the people that are enjoying
them um but I just still happy for that
don't really [ __ ] with lives oh it's the
morning toast I also like to do my own
lives I think I'll go live today will
you yeah just capitalise on you know
people's eyeballs yeah everyone's just
loving that live life we've in the live
life I'm so long we've been going live
we've been walking the walk and now
people are talking the talk it's like hi
yeah we've been live streaming Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
since April of 2018 welcome yeah but I
mean if people are enjoying it love to
see it love to see it so we are going to
dive in we also are going to do to your
toasters thank you guys for submitting
we got some great quarantine theme dear
toaster so that's what we're gonna doing
well that's what we're gonna do and we
are going to recap we're toast movie of
the day which was Heartbreakers and
we're gonna assign our next movie of the
day I didn't even the episode so join us
won't you
please please do okay without further
ado we have no concept of time but I'm
gonna go ahead and say it Dee's time
then we have no concept of time did you
know that it's hump day we didn't even
talk about that our favorite day here
the morning there's no days there's no
hours there's no weeks were just in
quarantine it's just blah day yeah it's
just bleh it's med day and it might be
time who knows it's a day Mayday Mayday
hold on
for the past five stories that you need
to know yes you because you literally
have nowhere else to go before you wake
up and take a bite out of your morning
toast and as much as we've been getting
lives like livestream concerts there's
one that I'm missing and it's from Chad
Hanks singing my favorite song you've
got that chata - dude you've got that
attitude and very appropriately because
we spoke about them literally yesterday
- today's episode is brought to you by
attitude I couldn't have dreamed up a
better sponsor for today's episode I
don't know why because I woke up in a
deep sweat you want to know why because
I had to change my own sheets and it
took me like six hours that I wasn't
able to put my attitude buns back on and
I literally blew my hair out before bed
and I will
in a deep sweat I had to redo my whole
hair and I guess you never really
realized how much of an impact the
attitude sheets have made on my night
sweats until I slept without them so if
you don't know about attitude they are
feathery soft I'm an editor at goop
actually said that her and boyfriend
haven't needed melatonin since their
first sleep on attitude sheets because
you sleep so much better they're made of
organic clean bamboo which is an
extremely breathable fabric it regulates
your temperature to improve your quality
of sleep so if you're someone like me
who literally cannot stop sweating in
their sleep attitude is a real
gamechanger they're also antimicrobial
so a lot of customers have claimed that
their skin's appearance actually
improved after switching to attitude
sheets I'm you can read the reviews
online for yourself and I never really
realize that you know like sheets and
towels can actually make a huge
difference on breakouts if they're not
clean or they're not made of good fabric
so another reason to get attitude their
organic clean bamboo is also recycled it
uses 90% of the 98% of the water that it
uses is recyclable so it's the most
sustainable bedding available cotton
uses a ton of pesticides and wastewater
that is harmful on the environment so
there's no reason not to try attitude
the amazing sheets have a 30-day
risk-free Trott risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your sheets for a full refund and
they either even cover the shipping on
returns so generous they're betting for
that attitude is the bedding for the
educated conscious consumer 100% organic
bamboo made with non-toxic manufacturing
process and a hypoallergenic and
antimicrobial um and if you want to
check out edited sheets they're soft as
silk breathable as linen but at the
price of cotton you're going to love
them and right now our listeners will
get 20% off their first 20% off their
sheet set and free shipping text toast
to six four zero zero zero the only way
to get 20% off your set of attitude
sheets and free shipping is to text
toasts to six four zero zero zero that's
TOA st two six four zero zero zero thank
you attitude sign-on sleep amazing okay
you guys it's probably it's day five day
six of quarantine now people are
starting to crack um it is d5 d6 of
quarantine but i'm i'm counting from
monday because that's when people
started working from home and over the
weekend people really weren't taking
quarantine seriously like my personal
quarter I'm on day six but I'm calling
it a three even though I'm on day like
four and a half yeah um and the first
egg to crack has been Vanessa Hudgens
oh yeah we actually called this
yesterday because we were saying that
Peter on Monday we said even though the
world
is barely turning people are you know
really panicked somehow people on
Twitter are still finding time to cancel
other people and Vanessa Hudgens is the
example of that not saying she didn't
you know deserve it but we're still
doing it just so in case anyone was
worried yes
so yesterday Instagram live what
circulated that she had posted where she
said commenting about how the crisis is
gonna last till July she said um yeah
till July sounds like a bunch of
[ __ ] I'm sorry but like it's a virus
I get it like I respect it but at the
same time like even if everybody gets it
like yeah people are going to die which
is terrible but like inevitable I don't
know maybe I shouldn't be doing this
right now it was a really bad clip maybe
even worse by the fact that you probably
can't tell just by reading it but if you
watch a video which we posted on our
Instagram she doesn't seem 100% there
yeah it's it's weird across the board
yeah it's like she got drunk and went on
live what you should never do and then
was talking about something kind of
sensitive but you should really never do
yeah and so obviously the internet
descended on her one because that's what
the internet does and to because they
have nothing better to do right now and
people are really upset about her
comments cuz they were really [ __ ] up
they were really [ __ ] up she wound up
hosting a video like sort of
backtracking on what she said and then
she posted a formal apology because I
think she realized like how big of a
deal it was because people are upset and
I think she now realized how [ __ ] up
what she said was so she posted an
apology to her Instagram notes up I want
to hear your thoughts because also and I
I felt like a media would have said
something differently on this show today
about what she'd said but then I read
Chrissy Teigen tweets yeah I know that
to where she just is reminding people
you know like um it's a crazy time like
people say the wrong things sometimes
but doesn't mean we all have to like
descend upon them and time ruin their
career and that's that's what I agree
with so I'm inclined to like defend
Vanessa Hudgens just because like the
what people are now saying about her is
so mean but what she said was so dumb
and [ __ ] up like what are you doing
and Woo's around you like who's
monitoring your social media like [ __ ]
yeah things like this don't just happen
like celebrities have so many like paper
between them and the public and oh my
god like we're like to not know to not
be able to take the temperature of
society
now and understand that people are
panicked people are freaking out and
they're really sensitive like what the
[ __ ] are you doing and I kind of
understand saying something crazy um for
the sake of a joke but she was being
serious yeah I think it's also like this
weird mind because I think a lot of
people are making coronavirus jokes and
as a society like we're here for them
because it's helping us get through I
think a lot of people like find light in
comedy we are some of those people and
so people are getting away with like
saying some crazy stuff and making jokes
about it because it's okay to make jokes
about things that scare you but this
wasn't a joke no this was not a joke it
was just really dumb it was really
really shame and I didn't even
understand her point okay so people are
gonna die and yes at some point
everyone's gonna die but we shouldn't be
worried because people are always gonna
die I just I didn't get the point maybe
if I'd understood the point I couldn't
disagreed with it but at least I
understood it I don't get what she was
trying to say no I don't get it either
and I was just the video was worrisome
like with her head like a rolling back
and forth like someone they need to take
her phone away from her just like if
you're gonna be drinking all day which
is what a lot of people are doing
because there's nothing better to do um
don't be going on Instagram ah you know
what I'm really glad you brought that up
because I was actually thinking about
having a drink last night I was just
like bored and I only have to watch
Vanderpump rules like I was just like
maybe I should have a wine like make a
margarita like I was so bored but I
didn't do it because I feel like I don't
know I just think like drinking in your
house is bad I don't know why I never
drink in my house and I feel like if I
started drinking during the quarantine
like I actually wouldn't stop and we
still have to wake up and do the show
like every normal day and I wouldn't
drink on a normal weekday in my house
that's true maybe you'll drink on Friday
I actually think I definitely will
if I were a drinker right now I would
have a drink
yeah I mean they say I've seen Snitch
like you know at night with her wine
while watching The Bachelor like I see
it I get it
by the way I think you should have a
drink I think I might have a drink on
Friday yeah but you you have drinks
during the week all the time I know
because I'm selling like I'm out to
dinner like it's part of that but you
should like make it a fun thing in your
house like but Ben won't have a drink in
the house he's like so bright it up I
doesn't need it you like made him a nice
drink he would drink it just at least to
be nice yeah but that's like I'm just
drunk in my house I just don't get it
yeah and then it like looks different
and like anywhere else the meme that
been posted yesterday about room about
room I was had tears streaming down my
face
I mean meme culture is thriving I have
really been having so much fun posting
memes and people aren't being that
sensitive to it like I think that of
course there are things about
coronavirus that are scary and sad but
people are really like open to making
fun of it almost because it's such like
what else can you do right yeah yeah so
I thought I would like be getting more
[ __ ] for like posting so many memes
about it but it's really they're funny
and they make me feel better and they're
getting us through agreed you know I've
been living for the memes keep talking
me in them totally
good morning lamp so when it comes to
Vanessa Hudgens I just say you know put
the phone down step away from the
Instagram likes ya blow up or someone
else will say something stupid yeah I
mean I'm according to Governor Cuomo
it's gonna be 45 days till we reach peak
what I read that this morning and like I
just can't so she will not be the last
okay yeah we're working on getting some
sort of expert here on the show because
again so much misinformation being
spread and we don't wanna be part of
that but that's crazy would you read
that I read it in my in my newsletter
need to know and they're always sir
always they're always on top of it
whether it's crazy I get it so 45 days
until the number of new cases daily
starts to go down yes yes and that's
from the New York Times so legit that's
on them yeah I thought that on that okay
next story a little fun conspiracy news
because Oprah is slamming a fake report
that she was arrested for sex
trafficking I hadn't seen the fake
report many oh I'm seeing Oprah tweeted
just got a phone call that my name is
trending and being trolled for some
awful fake thing it's not true haven't
been raided or arrested just sanitizing
and self distancing with the rest of the
world
stay safe everybody people just coming
for Oprah yes this has to do with the
conspiracy theory that we gave light to
yesterday oh you know Oh was that what
she was referring to yeah I didn't see
her name trending but maybe she saw that
was trending and she's wrapped up in
that but I mean I obviously don't fully
believe that transparency theory we
don't know the conspiracy theory we
referred to yesterday is something that
went a little viral on Twitter are
basically saying that coronavirus is
like this elaborate scheme made up by
like the rich and famous to take down
certain people in Hollywood in business
some certain rich and famous people who
are involved in some sort of like sector
sex trafficking pedophilia ring and
Harvey Weinstein gave them their names
it's like this really elaborate thing
that's definitely not true
but I didn't realize that this was
referring to that I believe they just
did that
I mean obviously Oprah's not a sex
trafficker she's like so busy I'm
running Weight Watchers and that really
is a full-time job those commercials are
so inspiring every time I see that I'm
like damn I need stop eating but then I
just go back to the kitchen I've been
eating so much I'm really like
struggling between going in on this
quarantine you know not because on the
one hand like I don't want to emerge
from quarantine like not feeling myself
but on the other hand what is there to
do other than eat I don't understand the
noble who are working out during their
Parnes Margot and their hoses I can't
relate
oh you can't you can't relate to been
turning over in the bed yesterday said
oh I just ordered a yoga mat and two
dumbbells on Amazon I said why it's
because you need to work out I'm like
okay but you're not not working out
right now because you don't have a yoga
mat you're just not working out because
you don't want to work out like it was
the ROI it's like the woods are getting
to him there I think today's his last
day on the roid prednisone packet and I
just can't wait for him to come back to
normal like he's being so crazy if you
see me working out in my apartment and
posting it you will know that I have
cracked oh and for sure yeah right now
I'm really just enjoying the frozen
pizza life and like I also feel like I
can't restrict my aura like try and
naughty because what is in two months
I'm so hungry there's no food and I'm
like oh my god I wish I ate what I had
yeah you know yep so I it's so hard but
then it's like I don't getting away
Twinkies so depressed you know what I
did everyone knows I'm have gas in my
building we're having like a problem
with con Edison and it's just that like
the worst possible time they don't have
a stove or an oven but I did order last
week a hot plate on Amazon and I got it
and I made pasta in it yesterday and it
worked perfectly
yeah I'm what kind of pasta just like a
plain I think it was a rigatoni and been
just added like a little sauce and like
a little butter and it was so good and
literally had it for lunch in me and Ben
split a box of pasta like we didn't
think were gonna finish it we're like
it's for leftover so just like make the
whole thing literally not a noodle left
Wow pastas they have my cross to bear is
so good because I don't have a strainer
oh and so I ordered one on Amazon I
don't have a strainer either so how do
you get the water out of the pasta um I
use like a little spoon no I am I'll
turn
the pot into the sink and I'll take a
paper plate you just like cover it it's
just it's not ideal it's not ideal so
actually a few months ago I ordered a
sharing her on Amazon and I received it
and at the bottom of the bowl was a
sticker for the product and they go to
take off the sticker and it's one of
these cheap [ __ ] stores that doesn't
come off in like the whole bowl is
filled with sticky and how am I supposed
to use this and I go to Amazon because I
was gonna return I'm like I can't I
can't break my nails on this like I
can't deal I'm gonna use baby oil or
makeup remover pads googan I have
everything it was not coming off a sheet
[ __ ] sticker so I went to the
reviews I was like is anyone else
struggling with this sticker oh my god
they went off they were like this bowl
this sticker who puts a sticker this big
on a bowl that you can't get off they
were like the bowl looks nice but I'll
never know but I had the foresight to
return in it smart and now I don't have
a strainer with a sticker the no
strainer at all house is my cross to
bear because it's so delicious and for
someone who is incapable of cooking it's
the easiest thing to make yeah
but without a strainer like my arms
aren't strong enough to hold that thing
it's really not that hard you just paper
plate I it's it is that hard so they
didn't amend the strainer for no reason
you lose it one two three noodles it's
home you lose a lot of beutel's it
depends what kind of noodles you are
making yeah because it's making little
elbows and they were so hiding away you
[ __ ] I didn't realize it was elbows
that changes everything
yeah I love an elbow because they can
pack so much flavor yeah and if you're
making mac and cheese like little extra
cheese gets stuck like under the shell
it's so good yeah I like just pockets if
we don't talk about shells or elbows
shell bows shells or shells and elbows I
think of the little used when I did it
the first time it was an easy with
shells love shells yeah but they were
mini shells and so they were sliding out
walkie Mack has been my actual cross to
bear because you don't need a pot for it
that is true it's so good I mean I also
bought the ones where you do need pot
yeah I got butter but hopefully and you
know they started making kraft mac and
cheese you know the little ones that you
microwave they made bigger portions for
the microwave it's so [ __ ] good and
it's huge
damn yeah I'm about to which is a big
mistakes already I gotta get on that I
made a frozen pizza last night I don't
have an oven I'm so good looks so good
I'm running low on frozen pizzas I also
brought frozen mac and cheese and also
got frozen waffles which I thought
wasn't smart like egg oh oh that is
smart frozen everything is
yeah leggo my [ __ ] echo [ __ ] okay
next up umm influencer Arielle Charnas
also known as something Navy test
positive for coronavirus the trying she
had a busy day yesterday yeah yesterday
was not the day to be art not only is
she sick I got tested for coronavirus
then she received a lot of backlash for
skipping the line for coronavirus tests
I saw this on dye Prada I saw it um I
saw her story of her getting swab Dan
and whatnot in her freaking out and
they're not freaking out and then like
deleting her story yeah and then it made
headlines and then dye Prada wrote it up
and now we hear from her yes and now we
hear from her she said quote I realize
that there are many individuals both in
New York City and nationwide who do not
have the ability to receive immediate
medical care at the first sign of
sickness and access to care is number
one priority in a time like this it is a
responsibility of our government offices
to ensure all Americans can access
necessary tests and I acknowledge how
lucky I am to have had that access so
people were coming down on her for
skipping the line and using her
privilege she got a test when doctors
had told her that she didn't need to get
tested right and I guess it's like if
you're a young person who has like a
flu-like and you probably have corona
virus they don't need to test you
because you just treat it like a normal
flu and you get better at home is out
the reasoning yeah well they might still
test you but I don't think any one that
she had been around had tested positive
for it so if you have been interacting
with someone who has it you you get
tested yeah no I mean it's incredible
some are also her symptoms like weren't
totally indicative that it was current
virus so they were just like stay at
home and also if you go to the hospital
get tested you might expose yourself to
it right so as a young person I guess
she was just instructed to stay home and
get better whether or not it was karna
merits cuz you don't need a medicine is
you just have to heal from it right yeah
so some situation so I think why people
are so upset about this is because it's
just it took a like out of touch to new
levels and I think that's why people
have people really really like something
maybe and that's why they choose to
follow her because she lives this lavish
life that's like so and relatable and
she's generally out of touch but people
don't mind cuz it's fun and interesting
to watch this life unfold but when
people are dying I just felt like you
got to be more self aware like
understanding that people who are old
have pre-existing conditions are
literally so so sick and they can't get
tested like I know someone in LA
who was with someone who had car
virus has been sick with the flu for two
weeks and they're only testing 50 people
a day in LA and cannot get tested like I
know and I've heard I've read a million
stories about me so just like being
aware of the fact like of course if you
have access to the virus to the test no
none of us would say that we would turn
it down if they were actually sick like
I don't fault her for that but just like
being aware of like what it looks like
and then literally going she got tested
in her car like they came out and then
running home and getting a package from
Louie Vuitton she got a brand new bag
like it was just it reached new levels
of out of touch and I think like we're
used to getting that kind of content
from her because like it's fabulous to
watch someone's life like that but like
we're living in serious times like you
got to be more self-aware yeah but I
think her posting today that she
actually indeed does have it might
change can you imagine if all this
happened and she didn't have it yeah
well I just assumed we weren't gonna
hear from her again cuz she deleted her
stories and I think she said she was
done posting that state content and kind
of made it a thing of like no one wants
to like watch sick content and she's
gonna go back to posting her kids and
yeah what not it was just you know he
was really not it was handled more like
if I was her like I just be grateful for
Vanessa Hudgens today ya know and people
love to come for her like I do
and you don't know who she is do you
remember a few months ago we reported on
Amanda Seyfried like weirdly commenting
on an influence influencers post who she
had no idea who she was just like coming
for her like and regardless of whether
and on her point was fair or not like
you she was just like coming so people
love to comfort cuz like she's literally
the face of privilege and people are
coming for her but I feel like at this
moment like she really handled the whole
situation very poorly yeah but I think
people will stop coming for her because
she has it right I don't know but this
is like her having it is the only thing
that could have salvaged the situation
like people were very upset at her the
comments on diet Prada we're [ __ ]
ruthless and then it just like takes it
to a place where like alright you don't
just say like mean things about her kids
like come on yeah and that's the same
thing with like Vanessa it's like we can
be upset with someone we can call them
out and like they can apologize but like
at a certain point you know you don't
have to show up at their house with
pitchforks until they lose their job
yeah I just think when you're when your
life is online and and you're used to
people being like sensitive to your
content especially in the time like this
like you should just take a step back
and really think before you post and
because everything I was watching in
real time because I follow her and I
like a lot of her content her kids are
really really cute it was just like oh
damn like I you were watching it unfold
like knowing like oh my god she's gonna
get so much [ __ ] for this and usually
she's like bloggers get [ __ ] like in
their GM's and like on reddit but not
really mainstream but because kovat is
such a mainstream thing right now like
she it was really escalated I just think
like you got to be more self-aware like
when you have that many followers and
you're already kind of like a polarizing
figure to some people yeah I would agree
with that okay you're ready for our next
story little Bevin news because amanda
Bynes is pregnant
well she's sparking a bright light in
this dark time that she's pregnant with
her first child as her on and off again
fiance Paul Michael shares an ultrasound
photo okay I love Amanda Bynes
and by the way I just rewatched
hairspray which was one of her final
performances and something that deserved
an Oscar yeah and I think she deserves
an Oscar um first she's a man for the
role that she played as viola and
Sebastian I think she should get it a
nomination for best manatee actor and
leading actress totally great but yeah I
do not care I know I do not care if
she's engaged if she's pregnant she got
another face tattoo like I don't care I
know and also like then she's engaged we
reported then she's not engaged someone
posted photo of an ultrasound I'm sure
we'll hear tomorrow like oh that's my
little niece I just like I'm out on this
I know like and it's in the toasters or
people are always sending me when like
she post something oh my god man Bynes
this man mind sad and so I feel obliged
to speak on it
but there's just not a bone in my body
that care no I know and it's hard for me
because I think for both of us like
growing up I we were some of her biggest
fans and even to this day like I regard
some of her work in the comedy space as
being transformative and I'm still a
really big fan of her and I'm still
really championing her like get back
into acting and get to a really good
place in her life especially with her
conservatorship but I really like don't
care and you know who else I feel this
way about I'm realizing Lindsay Lohan
like she wildest personal life she's
here she's there people are like she's
releasing music she's doing this I don't
care like if she wants to get him back
into acting I'll be the first one at the
movie theater to watch that film Herbie
fully loaded the sequel but if she wants
to go live on Instagram like I don't
give a [ __ ] except when she went like
trying to like save these Syrian
refugees and she they were like leave us
alone we live here like she was just
like acting like she was trying to
kidnap the kid and the mom was like get
the [ __ ] away from us that was shall
iconic and so funny
justice for those refugees who I don't
think even ended up being refugees but I
agree with you Lindsay Lohan like
I'm I think some of her work was
probably the greatest and I feel really
a lot of her her content defined me as a
female in the world but again don't care
like I just I don't care I think she's
an amazing actress like and I wish she
would get back to that but when it comes
to her like her sassy personal TV show
yeah I'm I'm out
I agree says yeah it's a weird genre of
celebrity who like you are obsessed with
but also don't care about yeah but it's
weird because I growing up I had a photo
of for Lindsay Lohan and my locker
it's like Chloe interest in like I'm a
huge fan of Chloe and like I actually
met her no it's not the same because
it's like I care about everything else
for Chloe it's just that thing has been
beaten like if she started dating
someone new I feel like oh my god close
meeting something new I don't think that
I would really yeah if she started
dating her dating life is just so
uninteresting to me what because she
started dating Brad Portis I mean okay
well know if she started dating someone
that you were like semi interested in
yeah of course of course like but
they're very few people like she the
date that I really care about and she
keeps dating the same person that's true
no I but I think that I think if she was
totally like dating someone else like
full-on exclusive relationship you would
care but we wouldn't know what that
feels like cuz it's been so long unless
it was Theo I can't say for sure
okay that's their next story Tom BRE
sorry I've been just like so forgetting
what I'm here to do oh yes I mean when
you have a sleeping the tremens snoring
on your lap it's easy to forget it's
easy to just like get lost in the
fisherman of it all but I'm really
starting to take a break very pertinent
today's episode is brought to you by
OkCupid if you haven't heard about it
yet it's everything you need to get
through the quarantine because you
should be productive with your time and
maybe meet someone we're here to tell
you why you should give it a shot a lot
of people don't know that OkCupid it has
really changed the game they ask you the
most thoughtful questions so that they
can learn more about you and what type
of person you're looking for the more
questions you answer on OkCupid the
better they aren't finding you matches
that you have something in common with
some of our favorite questions from the
OkCupid profile are do you find
intelligence sexier than looks how do
you feel about the 2020 election
intelligence sexier than looks honestly
yes oh yeah and I think if you find
someone and tell it was like love is
blind if you're attracted to someone's
brain like their physical attributes
become sexy know and also like I think
like I don't even look at what people
look like anymore you neither I'm really
not shallow
it's crazy because once you know someone
like they just look like what you know
of
um you know it's just love is crazy
honestly you can but we're in absolutely
no rush this is so true I'm just
thinking about love you know ya know and
so is OkCupid it actually works it's the
most mentioned dating app in the New
York Times wedding section it is the
only app in the world that can match you
in a range of issues you care about from
whether or not your dog you are a dog or
a cat person or how you feel about
climate change stop the mindless time on
dating apps and go to the app where you
choose what matters
OkCupid is free human connection is more
important now than ever with OkCupid you
can connect with something with someone
interesting online even plan a virtual
date download OkCupid today to connect
with someone great and I've said it once
I'll say it again if you meet someone on
OkCupid I will come to your wedding
I will officiate your wedding I was
singing your wedding um you have to go
on OkCupid right now now is the time to
meet someone you guys because then like
you can come out of the quarantine
actually I feel like who knows when the
quarantines over like I just might look
totally different yeah so um you would
have to like update those photos
afterwards but hopefully it won't be
like that hopefully are you okay yeah
I'm just like missing one of my ads but
I'll pull it up in my email okay cool
and I'll let you know that Tom Brady has
an agreement in place with the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers for a 30 million dollar per
year short track Wow I can't believe
that I was like pretty on the nose
yesterday I think actually I would have
ultimately bet that he was gonna go to
the Chargers just cuz he's a California
boy but I got the other half right he
went to the Buccaneers excited by that
you did are we now that every show is
pretty much like having to take a hiatus
we have become the epicenter of like
medical sports and celebrity yes and I
called it yesterday oh gee and I call
the business yeah and that's what you
can expect from yes pee toast yes we
have ESP at the toast yeah there's a 30%
chance that it's already raining so I
think this just goes to show like he's
really interested in good weather oh
yeah so actually I have good weather and
money yeah I could happen to catch some
of Zach's um sports programming
yesterday it's the good weather that
he's chasing no income tax apparently
the person who drafted him to the
Patriots back in 2000 when he was 199 to
pick in the draft and that guy took a
chance on him and obviously it worked
out well that guy now works for the book
yeah Ben was also explaining to me like
there were only a handful of teams he
could go to because most
have a quarterback that like is good and
that they like built the team around so
there was like only three or four teams
that had the money and the structure to
like bring in a quarterback like
obviously Ben wanted him to go to the
Giants but the Giants have like a new
young quarterback that they're grooming
to me the next time Brady so you can't
just take a break from him like so there
were only so many teams that had the
money and the infrastructure and the
perfect like formula and I guess Tampa
was it I can't like see Chazelle in
Tampa but maybe she'll have just a house
in Miami yeah I think she'll be in Miami
she'll commute to the games it's just so
weird because they're also a family so
like now these kids are gonna have to go
to like school in Tampa what about their
friends it's so sad yeah that's sad like
they have 30 million dollars but it's
it's not ideal it's not that sad you
know exciting like your dad's time
reading ya know it's like people have to
move around for the military and like
that's different you know they're not
getting thirty million dollars right so
I think this is exciting shaking up the
sports world shaking up Chicago I think
it's good I I wish him luck and
prosperity in this endeavor I think
it'll be good you know what are their
colors red wow it's gonna be actually
really weird to see him not in the
Patriots yeah it's gonna be really I'm
telling you this is gonna shake up the
NFL like for real
have you heard about the XFL yes I have
because our husband's mind went to a
game it's like a new league it's extreme
football II it's just so weird like you
don't see new sport leagues like popping
up you know no it's like um what show
was this Oh in Mad Men when some guy
like this kid has like a lot of money
and he wants to start like a cricket
league or something big and that they
need the advertising company and they're
like just taking his money even though
this is never gonna go anywhere right
but I do think the xml's gonna go at
places they got like a lot of money the
WWE guys like invested five hundred
million dollars and Ben went to a game
said was sick exciting and they put it
on TV now like once partial sports
starts like recapping it like it'll be
good and then once the tow starts
talking about it which is already
happening already happening I have it
set a game I'll sing the national anthem
whatever yeah so there's our the Fast
Five stories but I also saw a story that
I just wanted to share because it's a
little bit of positive news in a very
non positive time the career CEO says
that we have hired 2,000 people and have
10,000 openings in response to the
coronavirus demand I was just saying
this to Ben last night like I literally
wish I invested in like Kellogg's
grocery stores are thriving right now
everyone is heading to the grocery to
stock up
kroger which is a big grocery chain is
in a major hiring spree and a time when
a lot of people are losing their jobs
and so if you know someone know someone
or that's fantastic the name of the
store is business
Oh so if you live near a Kroger's check
it out I think she's a Kroger
there's no Kroger's in New York by the
way there so that's why we're unfamiliar
but this really is so interesting and I
was just saying to this to you before
the show Sara Foster did a really
interesting thing on her Instagram where
she was reading people's DMS saying how
their workplace is handling the crisis
and of course everyone's limited by
their like financial means but it was
interesting to see how like some people
are doing like the right like target is
really taking good care of their
employees but Whole Foods it's not like
Whole Foods sent out an email and it
actually got a lot of bad press I saw it
written up I think in BuzzFeed they sent
out a memo asking their full-time
employees to donate their paid time off
to other employees who are like
part-time which is just so weird because
Whole Foods is a very very successful
grocery store and grocery stores are the
only companies being successful right
now yeah and they're owned by Amazon
which is the biggest company in the
world and it's just like you're asking
your [ __ ] employees who you under pay
to donate their money no what are you
[ __ ] donate your money [ __ ] yes Jan
you donate your money Jeff that was
really upsetting but I like hearing
stories about companies that are doing
the right things even like small
scribbles I work for a law firm they're
taking care of everyone like people's
families I love hearing those good
positive stories if you're in the the
YouTube live stream let me know what
your company's doing I'm very interested
to see the ptosis
I heard taking amazing I mean Theo has
never been in better health yeah I heard
as head of culture like he's keeping
spirits up over at tienen and the
content is premium so that's all we can
really ask for if you can be hiring
during a panic like that is just that is
the American dream yes we'd love to see
it okay should we get into Vanderpump
rules recap yeah I was gonna read some
people some people's sings on the stream
but we're not there yet so I will do it
after the Vanderpump rules reeling day
for Jackson Britney I was there in real
life but you would never know it because
they literally coming out of the whole
thing not that I was ever miked but I
was I was in the action I had a front my
table was right by the dance floor like
it's like they went into their way to
just exclude me from that narrative
which I very much asked to be a part of
oh damn yeah it was really really
I mean I feel like your narrative was
kind of tied to chef and they showed
shipped why didn't know but I think they
had to show chef because it's cool that
another Bravo Liberty is there but I
think Shep like was supposed to have a
bigger role yeah there was a storyline I
could tell you guys cuz I was there
there was a storyline unfolding about
Sheena possibly wanting to hook up with
Shep and Shep I do believe filmed a few
scenes but they didn't end up hooking up
so the scenes were irrelevant right so I
think if that had panned out you would
have been in more scenes because you
were with Shep yeah maybe like you were
Shep's girls you know yeah maybe I was
like the competition yeah I would have
loved to see that unfold yeah its own
spin it was the groomsman that Sheena
did wind up hooking up with some ball
dude why was the after-party so bright
cuz they film damn thing but they could
tone down lights a little bit they
filming clubs all the time yeah that's
true I don't know it was really bright I
thought it was a beautiful wedding I
mean it was they're beautiful honestly
that whole situation is like a dream
wedding like to literally be in a castle
yeah in your hometown like looking so
beautiful like all your fancy friends
from LA and your home people are there
and like it was just a fairytale really
like I feel like that is a dream wedding
yeah and I thought she looked beautiful
I loved that her dress became a mini
dress afterwards it was so cute she
seems so happy
her parents are so cute something I
noticed that Lisa Vanderpump is
obviously a producer executive producer
on Vanderpump rules and there was
something weird that happened at the
wedding where and they showed it so I
was wondering why they cut it out
Britney's dad said that prayer before
they all ate which was like so Kentucky
and it was so cute and he said and let
also let us also pray for Lisa
Vanderpump like me she you know mourn
the death of her mom it was really
really nice um and Lisa made this like
we her face and she like was really
upset about it and they cut the whole
thing out but it was such a lovely thing
that I don't know why they cut it out
well they might have cut it out because
like she got upset about and she
shouldn't have and it makes her look bad
yeah of course but like it was beautiful
and she should have gotten upset and
also me and it's my understanding that
Brittany's dad got permission from Lee's
had to say that so she was being a drama
queen they also might have cut it out
because I don't think they wanted like
one negative thing yeah like I I he
wouldn't like think hard prom like the
one bad thing that happens in a day of
like real love yeah I agree I mean then
speaking of harping on the whole
negative thing of being Kristen and
Carter it was so cringy like I could
have died when she was like why do you
under because I [ __ ] love you like
want to be notebook I literally could
have died and they never really cleared
up why the next morning he was
the scheana and Kristen because he slept
in their bed and they have we're sharing
a bed and they have sex I mean maybe
they had sex and then scheana was with
her guy and then came in in the movie
but that is just so [ __ ] strange to
me like yeah that Kristen and Carter and
scheana would be in bed together like it
was and we never got like full clearance
on that and then scheana was like also
all over Peter like she was so messy I
can't
yeah but her hair looked great I was
actually noticing when they were sitting
outside and Carter ended up being in the
parking lot Sheena's hair looked
fantastic yes I like when she's having
fun and just like being the boy-crazy
queen that she is you know and like not
trying to pretend like she's not that
yeah I've actually wrote down a few
things I wanted to discuss because when
Dana back in LA when Dana went to brunch
with Danica and that other girl
Oh Raquel yeah and Danica was um just
being really judgmental about the whole
max thing when literally she has to blow
into a what's a cross like breathalyzer
in her car in order to start her car and
the way she just spoke about her GU I
was like she thought it was so close she
was like I was driving to like an after
party in the hills and like I just like
you know like had drank a little too
much and I'm just like to me and I say
this on the show all the time like if
you ever do UI like you're the worst
type of person you're an [ __ ] who
doesn't care about other people you put
other people in danger you put yourself
at risk like and you're an idiot but
obviously like you can learn from your
mistakes but she thought it was like the
coolest thing ever like she had a Fendi
purse like oh yeah like my day I can't
stand her and like her actively trying
to ruin Dana's relationship and having
success and by the way I think that
Dana's explanation of the drone Jones
there is a difference if he's at a fancy
Italian restaurant or if he's at Joan's
on third which is where he was and like
suspended manager Jonica being that
she's just catching them in a different
cycle of the hookup like I really don't
think that's it at all I couldn't agree
more
I loathe Danica she's my least favorite
actor with her and I love Dana and I
don't need Dana and Max to get back
together but I just am annoyed that
those girls like got what they wanted I
know and that they were right
they weren't though right but they were
able to convince Dana and they finally
got enough smoking guns together to
convince her that Max is a bad guy and I
get why Max is like not interested in
playing that stupid game but in the
preview for the rest of the season she
hooks up with Bret yeah she's like into
Bret so Sheena definitely [ __ ] hates
her now oh for sure
yeah I mean I just feel like Dana can do
better than both of them ratios it's
updating that sir these are the single
cast members on the show she's gonna
she's doing much history he's gonna play
the hand she's dealt yeah it was a good
episode I loved Jackson Britney I
believe in their love and um next up is
Stassi yeah
when Brittany's eighteen year old cousin
caught the bouquet that was so funny so
funny it was cute I couldn't I can't
stay off my phone like I know when I was
watching Heartbreakers anything I'm
watching the bold type like I'm on my
phone so much it's so not like me like I
I don't know what to do and you know
what makes it worse I posted four take
talks yesterday and then I just keep
wanting to check to talk to like see
what people are saying and if I've
embarrassed myself enough yet it's a
vicious cycle you know and so it's like
I want to keep posting tic TOCs but then
it changed me to my phone understand and
I can't focus on what I'm watching and
it's like I don't even care and I think
I need to pick up a book because
sometimes that's the only thing that can
get me off my phone or I need to like
hide my phone somewhere and just like
stay away from it but it's like what if
we go into mandatory quarantine like
that's something I know I need to know
of course did you get like an Amber
Alert remember that siren when there's
an Amber Alert your phone goes off there
was an alert and it set you to like a
link to learn more about chrono virus
which was interesting yeah to like Texas
number to get updates I didn't get a
sound from it but I saw it in my
notification we're gonna recap our toes
movie of the day and do deer toasters
and the rest of the show is brought to
you by Yamaha they've been focused on
audio for over 130 years and they have a
discreet new products that everyone
needs to know about when you're working
from home relying on laptop audio can
lead to a poor audio experience
resulting in misunderstandings
frustration and even stress or fatigue
to keep your team's functioning at a
normal level we're here to let you know
about one of Yamahas portable speaker
phones that should be a no-brainer in
your work from home kit it's a discreet
compact device that you could throw in a
bag and take anywhere it's packed with
technology to make you sound great on
conference calls and block out any
unnecessary background noise it even has
easy mute by mute buttons if your dog is
barking
your husband's bothering you or even
sirens are going off you can connect it
to any software like zoom Skype
Microsoft teams and you can listen to
music or the morning toast in between
calls give yourself in your team the
right tools to collaborate and keep your
business on track because Yamahas teams
are fellow toasters we got you guys 10%
off all their work from home devices so
the link you have to go to is you see
Yamaha comm slash toast for more
information that's led
you see Yamaha dot-com / toast check it
out
should we do Heartbreakers first or dear
toasters first okay
our toast movie of the day was
Heartbreakers it was available to stream
on Netflix sigourney weaver's finest
work jennifer Love Hewitt's finest work
I was really happy watching it that I
wasn't wrong like when we when we
assigned to the invention of lying we
hadn't seen in a really long time and I
think we were probably wrong about it
but we were not wrong no because it's
been one of our favorite movies forever
I feel like it's such a classic but also
underrated and a lot of people haven't
seen it so I'm glad we were able to
introduce it to you and even though it's
from the 90s like so much of it holds up
yeah it didn't seem got that I was
watching an older movie yeah like the
fashion holds up at lycée of cellphones
you know yeah jennifer Love Hewitt's
little body was just her body is
everything her clothes are everything
like the hair the shoes the purses it's
everything of the sort even the setting
in Palm Beach it's just like so fabulous
coming the breakers I was like I'm so
obsessed with everything about the movie
I'm curious if you guys for who are
watching it for the first time if you
loved it as much as we did and then also
now that I'm watching it like with a
more critical eye like so much about it
is [ __ ] up like when Sigourney Weaver
keeps hitting the old man over the head
like elder abuse no totally so much of
it is [ __ ] up and that that old man
was like gross but so funny and lovely
and he loved her yeah though he was
really gross um but like you came into
his life and like ruined it and murdered
him maybe like I feel like vomiting my
cigarettes it's literally just such a
funny movie and by the way who knew Ray
Liotta was a [ __ ] smoke show I know
oh my god so hot in there minding me of
Joe Gorga yes like Italian New Jersey he
was so handsome and I only know Ray
Liotta as like a grey old man and it
makes sense that he's the star that he
is now because he was he looks like
[ __ ] Frank Sinatra like he was so
handsome
ya know he's he was really great and I
love when he like teams up with the
girls yeah and it's so annoying that
like glorious stole their money also
like Sigourney Barbra is her name lying
- no but like then she actually stole
their money and then they they do get a
pack but like her lying to package it a
lie to her daughter and even when she
made 300k on the divorce like she said
on her she made 80 like I didn't
pick up on that stuff before giving in
and also now like that I'm such a tax
Queen like I totally see how you know
they do they don't pay taxes yeah of
course but as a tax Queen I know that
the IRS doesn't just show up at your
bank oh for sure but i-- i guess i never
understood how they lost their money
before that and yeah and it makes sense
now that the bank took everything um to
me the one thing that was weird about
the movie is that when it came out
obviously Sigourney Weaver isn't what
she is now but to me now she's like a
maternal older figure and just like
seeing her stick her tongue in like ray
Liotta's ear like wearing lingerie like
that didn't make me feel weird because
to me she's like a quintessential
grandma you know yeah no but she was 53
in the movie and like she literally
looks so y-you think yeah that's what I
read I'm pretty sure that's what the no
way Sigourney Weaver age she would have
to be like 70 now because when we came
out 20 years ago age how old is she now
she is 70 Wow oh my god she had a bangin
body bangin boxy to me like the movies I
have seen her and she plays like this
wise old figure so to see her being like
a raunchy like at times did make me feel
weird get you a girl who could do both
um I have many thoughts that I wrote
down the guy who Jennifer Love Hewitt
fell in love with like was so dopey like
I wished he was like a little cuter yeah
but he was cute like that he loved her
but whatever had to be like a little not
cute in order for him/her to just like
totally overlook him for so long yeah
then the movie was fantastic but it had
one major major flaw ooh
jennifer Love Hewitt's wedding dress oh
no I liked it oh my god it was horrible
like the whole movie she's like this
sexy mixin and like I thought she was
gonna come out and like a really looks
like I don't even know what I thought
but that heinous teacup dress was awful
oh no I liked it I actually did think
her mom was right about taking out the
bow of course I think that it would have
been even cuter but I think obviously
that's not what you or I would wear but
I think it's a classic silhouette she
looks like such a cutie and yet her most
old movie she's this vixen heartbreaker
like you know just using her looks to
seduce men but like in her wedding like
she was just being her cute self
terrible terrible like I'm so glad we
didn't see her in like a mermaid I can't
even tell you
terrible literally Tara
it was horrible she is adorable horrible
adorable horrible the looks were
everything the looks were everything the
fashion was on fleek the cars like I
thought it was really really well done
and I thought was a great selection for
a toast movie of the day I think so too
I hope you guys enjoyed it as much as we
always have so Jackie is selected this
today is this next film it is on Netflix
I happen to watch it a while back when I
was searching dub Cameron's catalog of
movies as one does and then I saw that
Loki she used in a movie with sophie
Turner Hailee Steinfeld and samuel
jackson called barely lethal and it is
on Netflix and that is our toast movie
of the day and I mean Netflix original
no no it's just like a direct-to-dvd
love a straight-to-dvd and I think I can
like bet that you've never seen it or
never heard of it and I think it's just
like the kind of movie that everyone's
always looking for it's just like a fun
easy movie with some people that you
love
so barely lethal is tomorrow's toast
movie of the day it's barely lethal it's
to take on barely legal because they're
young and legal thank you for explaining
that um and I think you guys you'll
you'll see the rest I'm excited I like
having a movie to watch I don't really
watch movies anymore i watch a lot of TV
shows so this is exciting and I can't
wait Thank You Jackie for your
recommendation and if it's bad it's your
fault
should we dive into now I'm scared but
ya know it's a lot of pressure to make
the movies I mean will I ever live down
little children also Jessica Alba's in
it
and Jaime King and Steve oh oh by the
way anything Jaime King is in is
fantastic I totally agree with that
she's really the actress like well she's
like not really an actress anymore but
she was for like ten minutes
a great actress she is like the female
version of that guy from barely from the
bold type who ever like if she's in your
movie and Paige it's gonna do poorly
yeah but I'm gonna love it but it's
gonna get canceled okay I'm Heart of
Dixie our next segment is dear toasters
which is art by segments which we do
every Wednesday you can email us to your
toasters at gmail.com we decided for
this week's
do your toaster segment we're gonna do a
quarantine theme so if you're having any
issues with your quarantine roommate or
anything feel free to reach out to us we
always keep it anonymous first up hello
ladies
my boyfriend and I decided to flee New
York for the quarantine to stay with his
parents
it is day one and a half and I'm already
seeing this maybe an issue with his mom
issue number one she's a stage five
clinger she just lingers around hard to
get alone time with my boyfriend let
alone
get worked on during work from home and
who knows how long we will be here issue
number two I get that they just got back
from a chip a trip but she like
literally keeps the house so dirty I
don't know what I can do I don't think
she has ever had someone come clean the
house can I do such say anything about
either of these issues we're close to my
deaf deal happy with the situation being
able to actually roam outside in nature
but this may get old after two plus
weeks
thanks corn stains this is on you I
don't know in what world yeah you would
not only is he he's they're not even
your in-laws because he's her boyfriend
like you sound like you're Merida you're
saying your in-laws and your family and
like you know you love each other like
first of all being with your boyfriend
during quarantine is a big hard enough I
was actually thinking like if I had it
just a boyfriend and I was living in the
city like what I quarantine with him or
would I stay at my apartment my
roommates like that's so much pressure
to put on a relationship and you're
gonna go be with his parents instead
just to like step outside it was a bold
decision I think that you are out of
control and this one's on you sis yeah
unfortunately I have to agree and you're
gonna have to ride it out both of these
issues there's something you could do
we're man-made issues maybe by evening
you might be able to be like hey Susie
like can I help it's like you need help
it around the house like I feel bad I'm
saying you're like let me pitch in let
me but just like that could come off
really rude both these situations like
it's her house like it's her rules I'm
sure they're like why is this girlfriend
at our house right now yeah he's not
family this was a big mistake and two
ladies everywhere a cautionary tale I
think some people just like take that
leap of just like assuming or someone's
family like way too quickly I agree and
it's like no like this is years of
building blocks of a relationship you're
not just a girlfriend and then you're
coming on the trips and you're coming to
stay with us and blah blah blah like
it's a process it's called cabin fever
and unless you're like ride-or-die have
legal documents sign that like you two
are bound together like stay home yeah
that was a big mistake sis and you're
gonna have to live with the consequences
yeah T mosquitoes tear corns teens I'm
losing my mind
honestly I have no clue how many days
I've been stuck in my house I think it's
approaching five but it could also be a
year I literally have lost track of time
anyway I'm locked here with my mom and
dad and two adorable King Charles
Cavaliers so you're in heaven usually we
all live our separate busy lives very
happily don't bother anyone and
occasionally come together for a dinner
but that peaceful relationship is over
all of my classes are online now
wake up early get ready start my day but
my parents seem to forget this I swear
to god they start blasting Amy Winehouse
through our home speakers at 9 a.m.
every morning as I'm trying to write an
essay a few days ago I walked down and
they were playing Monopoly and drinking
champagne at 10 a.m. my mom comes in
multiple times a day to ask stressful
questions and dance around my room I
think the world might be ending ok and
last thing I really need help with this
one my dad gave me this whole speech
yesterday at dinner that I need to use
this time off to do something good and
that employers and interviewers are
going to ask what I did with this time
to benefit the world I'm honestly not
trying to come off as a brat but what I
can't leave my house I have no idea how
I'm supposed to now save the world and
it's really been stressing me out any
thoughts on how to deal with my actually
insane family thanks for getting me
through this quarantine
towstee regards ok um you're not gonna
like what I have to say but your family
sounds amazing
you sound mean like your parents are
precious gems like trying to make the
most of this quarantine and keep it
positive and upbeat for you and like you
just don't see that ya like them playing
Monopoly and drinking champagne like
join them I don't know you know and by
the way manage your time you're a
college student you're not a research
scientist like you have you write a
paper for a few hours a day and then you
have the whole day if you're waking up
at 9:00 you're going to bed at 11:00 you
have 14 hours to hang out with your
parents like spend a few hours isolate
yourself and then have fun that sounds
fun also it sounds like if you just
throw them a bone and hang out with them
like they'll leave you alone when you
need to be left alone but like you like
being mean to them 24 hours of the day
like obviously they're gonna come and
that makes parents just want to hang out
with you and it's like I always ask act
like to come and check in on me and when
he checks in like I bother him like
really annoy him for two minutes and
then like I get tired and I fall asleep
but um if he just gives me that time
without me having to beg for it like
it'll be even shorter but when he like
stays away for hours and then I come in
with so much energy and he just doesn't
know what to do with me
quarantining is a formula and it's a
balance and it sounds like this girl's
not bouncing at all no and it sounds
like your parents are great they've
given you two lovely King Charles
Cavaliers to quarantine ways if you want
to send one my way I would love that
and by the way that question about like
interviewers for jobs great such a great
point such a dad thing to say yeah
and there's so many things you could do
like go viral on tick tock I don't know
yeah I mean I get that you're
prioritizing your homework but unless
you're like literally trying to cure
coronavirus like relax
we're like read some books and then be
like oh I wanted to spend this time like
bettering myself and reading because
it's not something
usually have time to do yeah you could
also like make it up I don't know you
seem like you're honestly just a
complainer
yeah like be grateful you have a lovely
home parents who love you champagne is
flowing dogs what's bad not literally
nothing okay our final do toasters do
toasters I'm obsessed with the toast and
the toast communit a don't know I don't
do without you too my trusty Steen's
thank you
here's the problem my boyfriend who I've
been with for only about a month are my
my boyfriend who I've been with for only
about a month are both being required to
work from home okay that was she missed
her and her boyfriend are both working
from home oh okay they're obviously
staying in as much as they possibly can
I love spending time all this time with
him it because my wait I'm sorry this
girl literally I'm right in English I
love spending all this time with him but
my butthole doesn't my stomach actually
hurts because I can't fart or [ __ ] and
there's no end in sight help a sister
out what does everyone else doing I have
poo pourri but he could still hear it in
my 500 square foot apartment Jackie
can't speak to this she sent herself to
the hospital when she first started
dating Zack because she refused to fart
a poop and you know what I've been
thinking about these girls at this time
and like when Zack and I were in month
three of dating and we were spending the
whole weekend together and I refused to
poop in his apartment and I started to
get really bad stomach pains then one
night I woke up in the middle of the
night with horrible pains and we had to
go to the hospital and basically it was
like a really long and embarrassing way
for me to realize that I just need to
poop when I need to poop so I think you
should tell your I mean first of all
then you also poop and you realize that
it's not a big deal like I used to be
the sort of person that I never pooped
at work and I never pooped out publicly
my body was trained to poop at 5:30 the
minute I got home from work but like I
realized that that's not cool like
literally nobody cares if you're pooping
or you're not pooping so I understand
why you're feeling this way it's totally
valid but you just need to get out of
your own head you absolutely have to go
to the bathroom go to the debt and like
tell your man that like by the way
listen I've been getting sick because
like I don't feel comfortable going to
the bathroom here um
so either maybe he could step out if
you're an apartment and he could like
maybe roam the hallways or just okay go
this is what you could do if you're
really so worried go to the bathroom put
a song on really loud do your thing you
can have the sink running and the shower
running and then also just take a shower
right after so he doesn't know how long
was poop and how long was shower yeah
because I know that's probably sending
your thing came out if you're in there
for so long as it takes you awhile to
get things moving because you're
so nervous so then it's just a poop
shower and it's like oh yeah I was
pooping for three minutes and I showered
for 20 yeah I like can't relate to this
at all like I could [ __ ] anywhere like
we are so different
I have shat in you know in the middle of
Bogota at an outdoor mall at a toilet
that didn't have a toilet seat like I
could [ __ ] anywhere I [ __ ] you know
takes an enema quick [ __ ] or two like
the time that people take two I take a
really long pee I like wash their hands
for 20 minutes I take one quick dump
like I'm so good at it I've gotten to
that place to where I can just go on a
dime but I have a problem with this -
your toasters because one detail we
glazed over is that her boyfriend I've
been together for about a month
why are you partying with the boy you've
been dating for three this is what I was
this is what the situation I was
thinking about say you started dating
someone a month ago and it's either
you're not gonna see them for a month or
you could really build up this
relationship like and this was the point
in my relationship with Zack when I
wasn't pooping this is too early three
weeks I agreed that about a month means
three weeks I agree that's too soon but
like that's I think a lot of people are
asking themselves that question we'd
rather not see your new person absence
makes I don't wanna lay in bed all day
and like have sex and so that's true
you're loving the quarantine if some
people want to lay in bed and like fart
and pick their nose and you can't do
that if you're having sex if you're in a
new relationship yeah yeah somebody
definitely poop because even if it
doesn't work out like you're gonna just
be annoyed that you didn't poop yeah
just take back your power and the whole
thing of doing it while you're also
showering is genius because then if you
shower right after um the smell has time
to go away and then like all the aroma
from your perfume and the hot water will
get rid of it immediately yeah and also
if you don't even want if you're like so
paranoid you don't even want him to know
that you poop at all which I totally
respect just say hey I'm going to shower
and take like the Orani minute shower
take a dump take a shower and then like
a really quick one I think that's a
great idea that's actually some really
good advice which we're always giving
here at the morning toast - your toaster
segment if you or someone you know
hopefully next week we might not have to
do a quarantine theme but if we are
still doing quarantine themed next week
email us dear toasters at gmail.com that
is our episode if you are looking for
more content there is no shortage TNN
has released a new episode of the snatch
alert today a new episode of mood with
lauren elizabeth is coming a new episode
of caviar dreams with margaret joseph's
and mini hani you guys know more about
like our business
caviar dreams tuna fish budget all about
like how we started where we're going
where we're at tomorrow will be a new
episode of maternity live where she is
going to announce her gender which is so
exciting and I am on today's episode of
mood I just checked and it's it's also
like different content than what we've
just yeah more about like mental health
back there you know just personal growth
so there's a lot of you got content to
keep you guys busy there's also new
patrons this month the morning to us
patreon is patreon.com/scishow morning
toast is eight dollars a month for five
extra episodes just Jackie and I you
know some videos some audio item tour is
coming to day people this has been a
year in the making because I moved in 11
months ago and I feel actually I'm not
ready but um I really want to share with
you guys my home and I think this is as
good as it's ever gonna be so what
better way to do it then right now on
patreon patreon calm slash the morning
toast anything else we need to plug no
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennial Morning Show
where we live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube right now
please subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that's Spotify iTunes stitcher public
video I already owe cashbox all the
places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find out the morning toast
maybe want to subscribe leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are I don't know have a
great day stay safe we're alone together
we'll see you tomorrow